all right
Antoinette Antoinette uh where you from
where'd you grow up I actually grew up
here in California in a small town
called
Ventura but I've been in Idaho for the
last 13
years tell me about your
family I have a brother
and um my mom and dad and about 10 years
old my dad left and moved to the east
coast so then it became me my mom and my
brother my mom was a single mom she uh
worked a
lot how' you describe your
childhood feel like my childhood was
good up until my dad left you know we I
felt like we were the quintessential we
just played Sports we were involved in
school my parents were involved and when
my parents got divorced everything kind
of fell
apart
the divorce is hard on
kids how far did you go to school how
far actually have my
associates what' you want to do well I
always wanted to be a detective oh
really yeah worked on the paralal I was
a paralal for about eight years up until
I started
using and so that was roughly what age
that you started well I started using
when I was young but my addiction didn't
get bad until the last couple years and
how old are you now I'm 37 37 and you're
using cocaine cocaine not crap right
cocaine I think you're the first cocaine
user I've had on my channel after doing
thousands of
these what what does the cocaine do for
you takes me away from everything gives
me that Rush makes me feel
alive makes me
feel but not for a long time right right
so so you have to use it again and again
you're just chasing it
yeah and where is that addiction taking
you it's an expensive one sometimes
right
yeah I sold my house like four years ago
made almost 200,000 off of it and I have
nothing to show for it
anymore everything's
gone are you working
now no I've been fired from the last
four jobs I've had can't seem to hold a
job
together
I was always that person who
was you know growing up I got in trouble
after my dad left and uh spent some time
in juvenile hall
and my family always told me you know I
was the bad one The Bad Seed so I went
to school and got my degree in criminal
justice to prove them wrong but here I
am with no job can't hold it together
thanks
and you you blame the the coke for
that I was in a
shooting uh about two years ago and
that's when I started using and my life
has just totally turned upside
down do you feel like it was the
separation of your parents that kind
of made the cocaine something you wanted
to use and use
consistently I don't know I never
thought I would do hard
drugs I don't
know but here you are
regardless it's been how many years now
that I've been using yeah two for solid
solid two years but pretty destructive
two years
right very destructive
do you have
kids I do I have a son where is he he's
Idaho I have him I have custody of him
and I have since he was a
baby and it's part of the reason I want
to get
clean
he's had to it's just he and I so he's
had to see firsthand
and everything that I go through he goes
through if you had your life to live
over again what what would you have done
differently so
much so much I I wish I would have never
touched Coke I would definitely not have
I've ever touched it it's like once I
touched it once it
was never
ending is there are there addicts in
your
family
no and emotionally what what are you
going
through when I come down I get emotional
about everything just
beat myself
up I don't even recognize myself in the
mirror
anymore so it's just hard I don't even I
don't know myself and I don't like that
I don't like who I
am do you have
friends
few lost a lot of friends the last
couple
years I've lost
everybody my brother doesn't talk to me
I don't get to see my niece and
nephew what do you think people that
don't use hard drugs like this don't
understand about
addiction that addiction does not
discriminate doesn't care who you are
you touch it once you think it's not
going to do that to you it's not going
to you're not going to get
addicted it's not going to happen to me
you know it's what I always thought but
that can't happen to
me how are you supporting yourself
now I
don't
I don't know how I pay my rent every
month I sell drugs a little bit here and
there do small side jobs
and I don't know how I come together
with it cuz I have no
job every month trying to get rent is
scary I need to get my life back
together you know cuz I don't like that
feeling of not knowing where rent's
going to come from and 30 days goes by
fast no and in this situation when your
back's against the
wall there are ways a woman can make
money but and I've done that
yeah but that's not an ideal way to go
through life no I did webcams for a
little
bit I've traded sex for
drugs things that I never thought I
would
do it's very common it's not just you
men do it too I think doesn't make it
any easier though no I don't just just
trying to make you not feel so terrible
about it
it's not just
you but you have an opportunity now
you're going to a program
yeah cautiously optimistic but I'm
excited you're going today right yeah
it's
great I'm super excited to go to the
uplift I reached out to Becky and you
know I have State Insurance where I live
now
and I didn't think that it would cover
rehab so when I reached out to Becky
I told her that you know I had just a
state insurance so I wouldn't be able to
go to rehab
and this whole time I've just wanted
somebody to like pull me out of it you
know just help me and everybody says
that they can help you they can help you
but I don't know how to help myself and
they don't know how to help me so Becky
said if you want this doesn't matter if
you don't have insurance you want it bad
enough I'll make it happen for
you
and so I said I
did but I'm
scared what's your biggest fear that I
can't do it that I can't stay
clean uplift is a very nice rehab very
nice
facility I'm excited to go but it almost
feels like an out of- body experience
you know
and I can say things like oh you get
your son back and you'll get your career
back and you get all these things back
but sometimes that's those are obvious
and they don't really help telling you
that I think sometimes this has more to
do with your
self-worth and just just loving yourself
rather than oh I'll get my life back
together that's exactly it but how do
you love yourself you know it's hard
to
[Music]
that but if you get your head
clear sometimes you can see things more
clearly and you'll make better decisions
I hope so yeah because you seem to have
the the ability to do the right
thing have you I mean have you seen
self-destructive behaviors in your life
follow along or is it just in been in
the last couple years just the last
couple years yeah so you just got off
the rails somehow and maybe you
can get back on track I hope
so I don't want to live like this
anymore I'm tired my body's tired my
mind is
tired what's been your lowest
point there's been so many it's hard to
pick
one the loneliness that it brings you
know
I got so deep in my using that
I sit in bed alone I sit at my house for
weeks by myself and lay bed and don't
move and just use it's not really fun to
use by yourself but here I am still
doing it you
know and the loneliness and the shame
and all that just makes
using an easy
solution but I can tell you I think if
if you
spent time in the rehab and got yourself
clean you'd feel some pride in
accomplishing that and that pride is
something that can really help
you keep the ball rolling and and just
stay on
track I hope so that's what Becky says
so I trust her
yeah what have you
learned in
this crazy journey of self-destruction
that you been
through nobody can help you really in
except for
yourself got to want it I like to think
I want it right now I like to think I
want it bad enough that I'm going to
make it happen and I'll stay clean but
you know I never thought I would be here
to begin with
so yeah addiction picks on any
anybody it's not just certain people or
people with a history it's it could be
anybody
well Antonette I wish you all the luck
in the world I'm excited for you thank
you you're going to a great place thank
you so
much and I'd love to do another talk
with you maybe down the road a bit
okay okay thank you very much
thanks